[Musique]
eh ben on y est voilà on était là y est
on est là aujourd'hui
on a pris quelques minutes de retard on
va tout répercutée jusqu'à la pause dej
y aura bien une pause entre
monsieur jancovici et l'oratrice
laurence berthe et à
et la pose de déjeuner qui était
initialement longue de deux heures on
voit la raccourcir de 30 minutes mais
pour permettre toujours qui est voilà
des pauses entre les conférences c'était
le petit point logistique
donc on est passé le grand bain
aujourd'hui
et donc certes il ya eu des happy few
hier qu en plus bénéficier d'ateliers
vous savez que c'est la course comme
chaque année ou en tout cas si vous
l'aviez oublié parce qu'il y avait eu
les deux dernières éditions comme
d'habitude c'était le coeur à nouveau et
toute l'équipe me fut pas en tout cas
s'est mobilisé pour cette dixième
édition à nouveau et
je vais simplement j'avais on a fait des
slides quand même nom que l'équipe
identité graphique autant qu'elle soit
quand même là est
génial si je fais ça
guy môquet ça marche à fait ok
donc oui
alors et bien sûr je meurs d'envié de
vous raconter les mille et un chausse
trapes une chausse trapes qu'on a pu
rencontrer depuis le début de
l'organisation de cet événement
alors là c'est un discours que j'ai
écrit avant d'apprendre qu'il y avait
des potentiels perturbations donc ça
vous dit l'ampleur des défis qu'on a dû
relever pour revenir en tout cas en
physique on pourrait même faire lire un
manuel un finalement de comment ça se
passe quand on dit une quinzaine de
bénévoles se met d'accord pour donner de
leur temps en plus de leur vie de
famille personnelle et pro pour
construire un truc qui a de la gueule
c'est vrai qu'après une édition qui a
été annulée en 2020 une autre qui s'est
fait en ligne qui a été un petit peu
qui nous a fait rester dans l'autre coin
et donc c'est qu'ils étaient un petit
peu frustrante pour ma part on l'a un
peu qui fait ce retour en physique alors
je dis pas ça parce que il ya dix kilos
de mnm ce qui vous attends tu ne t'en
fais pas uniquement
toutes les équipes qui ont mis les
aiment et n'aiment dans des sachets avec
des grands bien sûr 2,36 grammes chacun
et donc quand je pense à cette 10e
édition c'est d'abord à l'équipe
organisatrice plupart à auquel à
laquelle je pense évidemment que je
voulais remercier de d'avoir répondu
favorablement mais sollicitations de
aussi si on va le faire si si on va
inviter telle et telle personne si si il
va dire oui voilà et de m'avoir suivi
dans cette aventure qui était pas gagné
donc merci à l'équipe flux pas
oui pour info je suis une habitante
allemagne je suis président de
l'association jeu j'ai pigé eu l'honneur
d'organiser cette édition donc vous
voyez on a treize antennes en ce moment
dans quel pays généralement quand orco
vide on organise une soixante dizaine
d'événements à l'année et on a deux gros
événements vous êtes à l'un d'eux les
x10 est le suivant c'est les huit campe
est ce qu'on en fera cette année on est
en train de
solliciter d'antenne de grenoble ça et
c'est presque officiel je les dis voilà
grenoble mais c'est pas sûr donc on
compte sur vos tweets pour faire du
forcing et pour que ça se passe c'est
généralement en décembre et le x je sais
pas si vous connaissez le principe mais
il n'y a pas de programme à l'avance une
soirée inspirant cleverly soirée depuis
le samedi les gens viennent pitcher leur
sujet il ya un choix qui est fait c'est
comme ça que le programme se construit
bien sûr vous êtes invités à nous à nous
suivre sur les différents différents
réseaux nous avons à cela qu'il ya plus
de 2500 peut-être en mille personnes qui
échangent qui échangent basse écrit la d
3334 voilà ça peut changer depuis
trois-quatre jours
alors je vous disais que
ça avait de la gueule cet événement ça
c'est que mon avis bien sûr mais en tout
cas moi je suis hyper ravi des orateurs
et oratrice des animatrices et
animateurs qui étaient là aussi hier qui
font cette édition et j'ai content que
certains aient dit oui il ya plusieurs
mois et qu'ils ont maintenu en tout cas
leur venue aujourd'hui
c'était l'idée c'est d'avoir un contenu
un peu différent quand on parle de
curiosité quand on parle du x sans
frontières s'était de déborder des de
l'univers unique c'est pour ça qu'on a
une architecte qui va paraître tout à
l'heure qu'on a une ethnologue qu'on a
une neuroscientifique qu'on a
et
enfin pas mal d'autres profils et qui
vont notamment fin normalement vous
titiller sur des disciplines annexes
connexes complémentaires qui peuvent
aussi vous aider dans votre métier en
tout cas sortir sortir du cadre et
et puis voir vu que notre métier c'est
quand même de résoudre des problèmes en
tout cas d'améliorer la vie des
utilisateurs des consommateurs des des
clients et c'est en tout cas le défi
qu'on l'a a relevé un c c'est d'éviter
un mur si j'ai bien compris tous ces
histoires de co2 ch4 et autres no2 alors
aussi dioxyde de carbone méthane et
protoxyde d azote je crois bien mais on
aura une confirmation de soleure lance
pas pour rien que j'ai voulu leur donner
tous en fête avec la première conférence
donnée par jean marc jancovici dans
quelques instants
et donc il y aura davantage des changes
aussi il ya des pauses un peu plus
grande entre les conférences il ya moins
de conférences cette année et on a
installé des meetings pointe au 6e
dans le dans la cité des sciences dans
la cité des congrès où vous pourrez
poursuivre certains échanges avec les
orateurs et oratrice d'aujourd'hui
donc voilà ça c'était les animatrices
animateurs d'hier d'ateliers les
orateurs et oratrice
d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas 4 pages ainsi mes questions
pour après vous inquiétez pas les
sponsors évidemment c'est une composante
essentielle d'un événement on remercie
bien entendu de leur confiance de leurs
envies en tout cas d'être là aujourd'hui
de revenir en physique de faire partie
des acteurs qui comptent en tout cas
dans notre écosystème donc cgi qu'est
notre sponsor platine maif et wellpoint
qui sont nos sponsors
et puis bien sûr
perfectionne laptop nexton mirail testa
pic ludotic calliope les sponsors argent
il ya des gens qui nous suivent depuis
longtemps il ya des nouveaux et il y à
aussi société générale les bases amis
qui nous ont aidés à fournir de la vélo
typiques comme vous voyez en ce moment
donc ça aussi on a commencé à le faire
en 2019 et on tient toujours à le
proposer
pour rendre accessible vraiment cet
événement là et il ya aussi bien sûr des
exposants qui sont
aujourd'hui présents comme d'habitude
vous avez pu en voir certains donc il y
en a qui sont près des entrées du lampy
gaston berger d'autres sont plutôt à
gauche et à droite où est et ouest donc
n'hésitez pas à bien sûr à aller les
voir et échanger avec ceux qu'il avait
que et découvrir ce qu'il propose
ce que je vous souhaite maintenant c'est
tout et à tous un beaucoup de curiosité
d'ouvrir nos frontières et puis un bon
événement
et je vais présenter en quelques
instants donc jean marc jancovici quand
j'ai pensé à lui en novembre dernier ça
faisait grosso modo deux ans que j'avais
bouffer pas mal de vidéos de conférences
de l'interview de
ces questions visio aussi pendant le
confinement
voilà dans son salon et naturellement je
l'émission my wish list assez vite en me
disant que ce serait je pensais
naïvement que ce serait original de
l'invité et puis depuis qu'il ya eu la
bd qui est sorti un monde sans fin et le
livre le ptf il est passé un peu partout
et il nous a gardé un petit créneau donc
tant mieux
et a priori elle ne le jeu paraît pas de
cette rumeur que vous pourriez verdir le
prochain gouvernement ce n'est qu'une
rumeur et donc il est là aujourd'hui on
va en profiter il est bien sûr le
cofondateur de l'entreprise carbones
quatre présidents deux chiffres project
qui a notamment pour objet de limiter le
réchauffement climatique et nous rendre
résilient face à la raréfaction
énergétiques fossiles
le bilan carbone vous connaissez bien
sûr que les entreprises font qu'on doit
faire et bien cette méthode de
diagnostic
la paternité en revient à jean marc pour
information je lui laisse la parole je
vous souhaite un bon événement et merci
monsieur jancovici de venir sur scène on
vous écoute
[Applaudissements]
est ce que m les documents
je vous ai dis pas qu'il y ait des
charges
alors pour ceux qui sont pressés la
réponse est non et vous pouvez aller
directement à la pause puisque vous avez
compris que ce raccourci et en profiter
un peu plus que les autres le
nab il m'a grillé la politesse donc ce
matin j'ai une heure en tout peut-être
1h10 je ne sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de
questions je vais essayer de faire
raisonnablement court pour la
présentation est renvoyée puisque vous
êtes jeune et qu'internet n'a pas de
secrets pour vous
à de saines lectures comme celle ci ou à
des vidéos que vous pourrez trouver en
ligne
la d exposer plus complet on va dire sur
le contexte
est un peu grossier je pourrais dire la
merde dans laquelle nous sommes
cette bd elle doit beaucoup et elle doit
pas dont beaucoup évidemment à son
dessinateur sans dessinateur n'y a pas
de bd et donc tout ce qu'il y a donc
nous sommes répartis des rôles tout ce
qui est sympathique et appréciable dans
la bd c'est lui et le triste sire c'est
moi
je vais vous parler ce matin un peu de
changements climatiques et d'énergie et
je vais commencer pour vous parler de
changement climatique par vous emmener
au pays des hobbits connaissait le pays
des hobbits c'est à dire le pays où a
été tourné le seigneur des anneaux la
nouvelle zélande je vous emmène au pays
des hobbits en 1912 et en 1912 un
journal un peu moins notoires que le
monde où l'express en france aujourd'hui
voyez une gazette de chez pas quoi
publie un petit entrefilet dans le
scientifique dans le journal 1912 un que
vous êtes tous des anglicistes
distinguez vous allez pouvoir lire ce
qu'il ya dessus en 1912 au pays des
hobbits on sait que le co2 émis par la
combustion du charbon où s'accumule dans
l'atmosphère que ça provoque une
augmentation de la température par un
effet de couvertures et ses marques et
blanquette et que les fai pourraient
être considérables il marquait
considérables à l'échelle de quelques
siècles
donc en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique provoqué par les activités
humaines et notamment l'utilisation des
combustibles fossiles
ça date pas de la semaine dernière ça
date pas d'il ya 10 ans sa date pas d'il
ya trente ans sa date de plus d'un
siècle en fait ça date même de deux
siècles que la base les bases
scientifiques de cette affaire ont été
jetés
célébrera dans deux ans si les petits
cochons et monsieur poutine ne nous ont
pas mangé avant le bicentenaire de la
découverte de l'effet de serre par
joseph fourier scientifiques français et
quelques dizaines d'années après la
découverte des gaz à effet de serre par
une brochette de physiciens dont une
femme à savoir le dioxyde de carbone et
la vapeur d'eau les deux principaux gaz
à effet de serre présents dans
l'atmosphère donc cette affaire de
changement climatique elle repose sur
des bases scientifiques qui sont très
anciennes ce qui est beaucoup plus
récent c'est d'avoir été capable de
confronter ce qui nous attend aux
évolutions passées et de comprendre si
on était plutôt dans le registre de
l'accélération à laquelle on résiste ou
du fait qu'on va rentrer dans le mur
voilà c'est ça qui est beaucoup plus
récent est évidemment la réponse c'est
plus proche du mur malheureusement que
l'accélération à laquelle on va résister
le climat a toujours variées sur terre
depuis qu' un climat sur terre c'est à
dire depuis qu'il ya une atmosphère
depuis 4 milliards d'années ça en impose
un peu le la terre latmos le pardon
notre planète comporte une atmosphère et
donc comporte un système climatique
vous avez appris à l'école probablement
qu'il ya longtemps il ya eu des airs
glaciaire il ya encore plus longtemps il
ya eu des climats extrêmement chaud des
dinosaures et c'est donc le climat a
toujours variées sur terre sous l'effet
de la variation d'un certain nombre de
paramètres astronomiques ou de la
géographie ou la géologie plus
exactement terrestre récemment ce qui
s'est mis à faire varier le climat avant
toute chose c'est nos activités et le
fait que l'on enrichissent l'atmosphère
en gaz à effet de serre alors ces gaz à
effet de serre ils ont une définition
très simple en physique cd gaz qui ont
la capacité d'absorber les infrarouges
terrestre c'est ça la capacité sur la
définition physique d'un gaz à effet de
serre changement climatique c'est avant
tout de la physique alors c'est
évidemment très désagréable pour les
gens qui aiment pas la physique mais si
on veut bien parler et bien s'occuper de
climat il faut avoir compris un certain
nombre de trucs élémentaires en physique
sinon on n'y arrive pas d'où la tribune
que j'ai eu l'honneur de signer il n'y a
pas très longtemps est parue dans le jdd
qui appelait le nouveau gouvernement se
farcir 20 heures de cours pour
comprendre un peu de quoi il retourne
parce que être nommé ministre c'est pas
comme réussir un examen ça ne fait pas
de vous quelqu'un de compétent dans un
sujet technique donnée juste parce que
vous avez été nommé
dans le contexte de la vème république
ça fait surtout de vous quelqu'un
d'obéissance
donc c'est la règle à ne faut pas voilà
ces cahiers des charges et de confiance
à peu près donc le la perturbation que
nous que nous imposons aujourd'hui au
système climatique est une perturbation
physique on va enrichir l'atmosphère
avec des gaz qui intercepte un peu plus
les infrarouges terrestre et de ce fait
créer un effet de couvertures avec tout
un tas de perturbations que je vais vous
décrire sommairement
cet enrichissement il vient donc de
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre de la
part des hommes alors on en est mais à
partir de l'utilisation du charbon
utilisé du charbon c'est de brûler
essentiellement et brûler du charbon
c'est oxydé du carbone vous savez le
charbon c'est essentiellement du carbone
avec eux de descendre un peu du temps
gêne un peu c'est donc brûler du charbon
celles associées à l'oxygène et créer du
dioxyde de carbone donc ça ça fait des
émissions
brûler du pétrole même motif même
punition c'est oxydé du carbone et
d'hydrogène et ça fait des émissions
brûler du gaz même si le gaz naturel en
légendant gens du qui font du marketing
pour le pétrole et le charbon ont un peu
manqué d'imagination si dans cette salle
parce que le pétrole est tout aussi
naturel que le gaz et le charbon est
tout aussi naturel que le gaz donc on
aurait pu parler depuis l'origine de
pétrole naturel et de charbon naturelle
naturelle c'est bon pour vous
donc le gaz naturel en fait c'est le gaz
qu'on trouve sur terre par opposition au
gaz de ville qui était artificielle dans
l'ancien temps et ça émet du co2 après
anvers vous avez la déforestation qui
émet du co2 la déforestation sur terre
c'est essentiellement je coupe je brûle
pour laisser pour supprimer de la forêt
et mettre à la place des surfaces
agricoles c'est essentiellement drivée
par l'augmentation démographique et le
fait que l'on mange plus de viande
ensuite vous avez des émissions de
méthane qui viennent à parité des
activités agricoles et de l'utilisation
des combustibles fossiles et enfin au
dessus vous avez le fameux protoxyde
d'azoté dont on vous a parlé tout à
l'heure qui se trouve être le gaz
hilarant serra qui sert également
d'anesthésiant léger dans les hôpitaux
alors ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre voyez qu'elle augmente également
bellis depuis un siècle et demi est en
fait une des choses que je vais tout de
suite vous dire pour doucher les
optimistes s'il y en a dans cette salle
c'est qu' aucune innovation technique
depuis que nous avons des ingénieurs
géniaux faisant du design enfin
exactement faisant de l'internet génial
permettant de faire du design génial n'a
jamais mis au point quoi que ce soit qui
de lui même à limiter la hausse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre aucune
innovation technique jusqu'à maintenant
nadel même limité la hausse voyez je
peux placer un certain nombre
d'innovations techniques sur ce
graphique par exemple électricité
commerciale commence à apparaître il ya
un peu plus d'un siècle
l'électricité s'est surtout développée
au cours de la deuxième moitié du xxème
siècle il faut savoir par exemple que la
production électrique mondiale mondiale
comme aurait dit coluche en 1945 était
juste un peu supérieure à la production
électrique française
dia quelques années
juste pour l'ensemble du monde donc
l'explosion de l'électricité c'est la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle ben vous
voyez sur cette courbe sera
manifestement pas beaucoup fait baisser
les émissions
on a mis les gens dans les villes il
paraît que c'est vachement efficace les
villes on se déplace moins vador bon y'a
plus en plus de villes on n'est même
plus en plus
on a fait plus en plus de train on les
met plus en plus on a fait de plus en
plus de numérique on aimait de plus en
plus et on a fait de plus en plus de
trucs et de machins le métavers c laude
musk qui valait sur mars tout ça ne
change rien
quand vous regardez les émissions à
l'échelle planétaire j'insiste aucune
innovation technique aucune d'elle même
n'a jamais limité la hausse des
émissions
donc c'est l'ingénieur qui vous le dit
penser qu'à l'avenir il suffit de donner
les clés du camion c'est le cas de le
dire à des ingénieurs en disant ils vont
nous trouver des trucs techniques et
problème va être réglé faut pas compter
dessus
la résolution du problème ne viendra pas
de là
viendra pas de la
principal gaz à effet de serre qu'on
aimait dans l'atmosphère donc le dioxyde
de carbone le dictionnaire est bien fait
c'est un oxyde dioxyde de carbone oxydes
alors là je vais encore un tout petit
peu vous faire mal au crâne je vais pas
vous parler de physique mais de chimie
il se trouve que sur terre les oxydes
sont des molécules extrêmement stable
dit autrement si vous ne leur ramenait
pas de l'énergie pour changer leur forme
elles sont éternels vous avez par
exemple un oxyde que vous utilisez tous
les jours enfin je souhaite pour votre
conjoint qui s'appelle l' oxyde de
dihydrogène
ça s'appelle de l'eau donc tous les
jours vous l'avez sous les bras et
ailleurs sinon vous sentez pas bon et
votre conjoint ou spaihts et bien
l'occident de dihydrogène donc l'eau est
présent sous forme de dons depuis 4
milliards d'années sur terre les hawks
ichihashi stable une fois qu'une
molécule est sous forme de kidal est
bien depuis cas de l'oxygène dans l'air
tout le fer disponibles sur terre est
disponible sous forme d'oxydé de fer
corps donc les quelques centaines de
millions d'années donc les oxydes sont
des molécules très stable le co2 n'y
fait pas exception une fois qu'il est
dans l'atmosphère or contact du sol il
est éternel il n'y a pas de processus
pour tanner déploration donc si vous
rajoutez du co2 dans l'atmosphère tant
qu'il ne revient pas au contact du sol
bail reste là
pour que l'atmosphère s'épurant co2 en
réponse à des émissions dans
l'atmosphère qui ont lieu il faut que le
co2 reviennent au contact du sol où il
peut lui arriver l'une des deux choses
suivantes il peut se dissoudre dans
l'océan c'est un processus de vases
communicants tout bêtement un don qu'il
se mette dans l'océan en cas de la place
puis quand y'a plus de plasma il va pas
et il peut être repris par la vie c'est
à dire la photosynthèse mais pour sa
fauqué de la vie donc plus le changement
climatique va affaiblir les écosystèmes
est plus ce qu on appelle le plus
terrestre va s'affaiblir vous avez un
phénomène d'emballement une espèce de
cercle vicieux alors comme ce processus
est très lent ce processus de reprise du
co2 par les écosystèmes où l'océan il ya
une très mauvaise nouvelle qui est que à
cause de cette très grande stabilité
chimique du co2 dans l'atmosphère nous
avons enclenché une expérience qui est
désormais irréversible
alors je vais vous l'illustré avec ce
graphique
le fait d'avoir rajouté du co2 dans
l'atmosphère a créé un surplus dans
l'atmosphère il ya plus de co2 que avant
qu'on ait commencé à faire joujou avec
les centrales à charbon les voitures et
les cimenteries
si demain matin on arrête les émissions
d'accord on les arrête totalement demain
matin qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce
surplus est bien ce graphique vous donne
la réponse un siècle après arrêt complet
des émissions à peu près la moitié du
surplus est toujours présent dans
l'atmosphère
milan après arrêt des émissions à peu
près 20% du surplus est toujours présent
dans l'atmosphère dix mille ans après
l'arrêt des émissions 10 à 15% du
surplus est toujours présent dans
l'atmosphère donc ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que du restant
des temps historiques quelques milliers
d'années
l'atmosphère ne reviendra jamais dans
l'état dans lequel elle était avant
qu'on commence à utiliser des
combustibles fossiles
jamais et comme une partie des
conséquences du changement climatique
déry directement de ce surplus de co2
dans l'atmosphère
ça veut dire que le système climatique
et les écosystèmes associés ne
reviendront jamais dans l'état dans
lequel ils sont aujourd'hui
l'état dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui va au fil des décennies et
des siècles à venir disparaître à tout
jamais pour des milliers d'années et on
ne peut rien faire contre ça ce qu'on
peut encore faire c'est modérer la
hausse c'est à dire qu'on peut modérer
la vitesse de la dérive et l'ampleur des
conséquences à terme ça on peut même
dire qu'on va remettre le système dans
son état initial c'est fini comme dit
p'tit gibus dans la guerre des boutons
fallait pas venir si j'avais su j'aurais
pas venu voilà mais on ne peut plus
revenir en arrière
ça pose évidemment des problèmes très
importants dans notre société de
l'instantané à laquelle vous contribuez
puisque internet contribue à
l'instantané
puisque nous avons un pas de temps ici à
gérer qui est très au delà des pas de
temps que nous avons l'habitude de gérer
que nous avions l'habitude de gérer donc
ça va très au delà d'une ou plusieurs
vies humaines et par ailleurs ça va très
au delà des pas de temps avec lesquels
on gère aujourd'hui nos organisations
alors le monde politique se gère au
rythme des élections mais vous rigolez
vos clients ou les entreprises qui vous
emploient ou et sponsors qu'on a
mentionné tout à l'heure se gère au pas
de temps de quelques années la stratégie
de long terme dans une entreprise cotée
en bourse ces trois en six mois les
mauvaises années la stratégie de long
terme dans une pme carbone 4 est une pme
ces quelques années donc on a l'habitude
aujourd'hui de gérer la société avec des
pâtes tant qu'ils sont en complet
décalage avec les pas de temps qu'il
faudrait avoir en tête pour gérer ce
problème là d'où le thème de la
planification cauchy project on a essayé
de pousser en avant à l'occasion des
quelques années qui viennent de
s'écouler et une planification c'est
très clairement un système contraignant
est stable c'est ça une planification
c'est un système contraignant est stable
c'est-à-dire qu'on se dit ouais voilà
par exemple et des gens qui planifient
leurs études sur 10 ans ou 20 ans
planifier les études de vos enfants
c'est contraignant font pas ce qu'ils
veulent et s'est raisonnablement stable
si tous les 6 mois vous changer
d'orientation professionnelle c'est un
peu compliqué
voilà c'est ça une planification alors à
cause de la très grande stabilité du co2
dans l'atmosphère est bien la
concentration de co2 augmente
régulièrement et alors autre chose que
je vais vous dire pour continuer à
toucher les optimistes s'il en reste
c'est que les coptes ne sert strictement
à rien vous à vous savez les réunions
annuelles du climat l'aï si vous avez la
concentration atmosphérique en co2 dans
l'atmosphère est ici je vous mets la
première coop c'est à dire trois ans
après que la convention climat a été
signé à rioz alors vous voyez
l'évolution avant et vous voyez
l'évolution après donc là vous avez
typiquement une expérience où vous avez
un paramètre qui n'a pas l'importance
dans l'expérience c'est l'existence des
coop on peut vous en mettre d'autres
alors il ya des succès il ya des échecs
en fait jusqu'à maintenant ça ne fait
strictement aucune différence
pourquoi est ce que c'est normal que ça
ne fasse aucune différence parce que les
cops et des système onusien dans
lesquels tous décident à l'unanimité
donc il se passera des choses dans les
coop une fois que les pays auront
commencé à faire le ménage chez eux il
ne faut attendre aucune aide d'une coop
au sens où tant que les pays ont pas
décidé de prendre le problème à bras le
corps chez eux c'est pas un miracle venu
de l'extérieur qui va régler le problème
à notre place
ça ne marchera pas ça ne peut pas
marcher
alors plus de co2 dans l'air qu'est ce
que ça va faire sur la moyenne de la
température vous avez ici une courbe qui
sort du dernier rapport du giec et qui
vous donne une réponse le 0 de référence
sur cet axe vertical c'est la
température moyenne de la planète sur la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle donc 1850
à 19 cents ce que vous voyez c'est qu'à
la fin du xxème siècle sous l'effet de
nos activités et ça ça ne souffre aucune
espèce d'ambiguïté la température
moyenne de la planète avaient déjà
augmenté d'un peu plus d'un degré alors
un peu plus un peu plus d'un degré
qu'est-ce qu'on a récupéré on a déjà tué
15 % des coraux on a même si on
stabilisait la température à la valeur
actuelle le stress hydrique qu'on a
commencé à imposer aux forêts françaises
par exemple battu et une partie de la
forêt même s'ils ont stabilisé la
température à la valeur actuelle vous
avez des récoltes qui commence à
souffrir ici et là vous avez des
sécheresses croissante qui commencent à
apparaître ici et là vous avez l'année
dernière au canada 50 degrés l'année
dernière en europe 50 degrés en ce
moment au pakistan 50 degrés n'ont pas
trait dans quelques jours en france 36
degrés au mois de mai voilà donc ça
c'est juste 1,1 degré 1 et vous voyez
les projections de température pour
l'avenir en fonction du scénario qu'on
va suivre alors le scénario du bas ces
accords de paris vous verrez à la fin ce
que ça signifie en termes d'efforts
c'est clair que c'est pas du tout le
monde dans lequel on vit
et le scénario duo ses torts qu'on a du
charbon on tape dedans alors marais vous
vous dépendez tous du charbon dans cette
salle parce que l'internet mondial
dépend du charbon
j'y viendrai après dans les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de l'internet
mondial vous allez trouver la
fabrication des écrans tout ça c'est des
pays asiatiques dépendant du charbon
vous allez trouver de l'électricité
c'est beau et de charbon dont vous
dépendez toutes et tous du charbon dans
cette salle au premier rang
anecdotique au premier rendre vous êtes
des amis du charbon
dans les scénarios que je vous présente
là vous voyez que ils sont trés
discriminés à l'échelle du siècle par
contre sur les 20 prochaines années ils
sont très semblables ça veut dire quoi
ça renvoie à l'inertie que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et notamment à l'inertie
qui est issu du co2 fin du temps
résidence d'un surplus de co2 dans
l'atmosphère en fait nous sommes dans
une voiture ou si on commence à appuyer
sur la [ __ ] de frein la seule garantie
qu'on a pour les 20 ans qui viennent
c'est que la voiture continue
d'accélérer quelle que soit la force
avec laquelle on appuie sur la [ __ ] de
frein c'est après qu'on va commencer à
voir la différence
ce qui veut dire que si on commence à
secouer les fesses au moment où les
emmerdements sérieux sont déjà là la
seule garantie qu'on a à ce moment là
c'est qu'ils augmentent
c'est un problème très compliqué le
changement climatique parce qu'on est
obligés de faire des efforts maximaux
pour éviter un problème qu'on n'a pas
encore vu
c'est compliqué hein on n'est pas câblé
pour ça hein on est des animaux ont
réagi avec nos sens nos sens ils me
disent combien de personnes ya dans
cette salle mais sens me disent pas
combien de personnes et sur terre ça
c'est ma cervelle qui me le dit beaucoup
plus compliqué à figurer un
à l'échelle du siècle ce que vous voyez
c'est que l'on parle d'une élévation de
température de quelques degrés en
fonction du scénario qu'on suit et on va
essayer maintenant de comprendre ce que
ça peut vouloir dire en regardant le
passé vous avez ici l'europe alors je
suis désolé de temps en temps je me
plante de slide l ai pas vraiment
actuelle l'europe que je vous montre là
c'est plutôt l'europe pré industriel
c'est-à-dire les écosystèmes qu'on
trouve en europe avant que le changement
climatique se déclenche à ce moment ce
qu'on trouve en europe c'est
essentiellement des forêts sauf à ce
qu'on les coupe pour faire autre chose
et on les a beaucoup coupé pour faire
autre chose en europe notamment des
champs
ce qui veut dire que les végétaux
naturels que l'on trouve en europe c'est
essentiellement des arbres c'est gros et
ça se porte bien parce que il fait pas
trop chaud pas trop froid et il pleut
suffisamment
voilà l'europe ya vingt mille ans alors
il ya vingt mille ans nous sommes au
coeur de la dernière ère glaciaire sur
terre le climat est très différent il
est beaucoup plus froid et vous voyez
que la géographie européenne est très
différente de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
alors la première chose c'est que vous
n'avez pas besoin d'apprendre le suédois
pour faire des sites en suédois n'y a
pas de faits doit au moins un problème
de résolu
toute la scandinavie et sous la glace
de même très bonne nouvelle pour le
quinze de france que l'irlande et
l'ecosse surtout l'irlande nikos on gère
mieux
des normes calotte de glace sont
également posées sur le canada et sur le
nord de la sibérie
pour constituer ses calotte il a fallu
de l'eau d'un glaçon il faut de l'eau et
l'eau qui a permis de constituer ces
calotte est essentiellement venues de
l'océan la nature a fait un transfert
d'eau par évaporation précipitations de
l'océan vers les continents et il ya
tellement d'eau qui a été pris dans
l'océan que le niveau de l'océan a
baissé de 100 m 120 pour être plus
précis donc il n'ya pas de club de voile
cgi dans la manche n'y a pas de manche
il ya pas de paradis fiscaux dans la
manche non plus petits pots de manche il
n'y a pas de break situe ce qui est la
continuité territoriale avec les anglais
voyez que le trait de côte et beaucoup
plus différent
sur l'atlantique sur la méditerranée
parce que les côtes méditerranéennes
sont beaucoup plus d'accord le
le fonds des sens beaucoup plus vite
quand on s'éloigne de la côte est donc
ça fait pas tellement de différence et
pour ceux qui connaissent l'anecdote on
rentre dans la grotte cosquer à pied
le climat étant beaucoup plus froid il
est beaucoup plus sec et ça vous donne
les écosystèmes maigrichon en europe qui
ressemble essentiellement est ce que
vous trouvez aujourd'hui au nord de la
scandinavie et dans ces écosystèmes
maigrichon vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
clients pour consulter au site internet
puisque la population française est de
l'ordre de celle d'une petite ville
d'aujourd'hui une fraction de
l'agglomération grenobloise où vous
allez faire un campement en décembre que
j'espère très sympathique pour donc le
climat très différent d'aujourd'hui
quand l'europe est passée de l'état de
gauche à l'état de droite ça c'est
évidemment opérées dans le cadre d'un
réchauffement climatique global qui a
marqué la fin de l'ère glaciaire la
déglaciation ce réchauffement climatique
global n'a été que de 4 à 5 degrés en
dix mille ans donc là vous voyez le
résultat d'une expérience grandeur
nature que la planète a fait pour nous
entre ya vingt mille ans et il ya dix
mille ans consistant à réchauffer le
climat de quelques degrés andy voilà
quelques degrés en débit lent et vous
voyez le changement extrêmement massif
de géographie que cela induit alors
maintenant je vais vous présenter la
même chose avec une courbe
surtout quand elles sont très belles
vous avez ici donc une très belle courbe
qui vous représente la variation de la
température moyenne de la planète sur
les dix mille dernières années alors
vous voyez que cette température a été
avec le même la même échelle de
référence que cette température a été
remarquablement stable et en fait si
nous sommes dans cette salle aujourd'hui
on le doit à ça on le doit au fait que
pendant dix mille ans le climat était
très stable ce qui perd ce qui a permis
l'émergence des sociétés sédentaires
dont nous sommes les lointains
descendants
voilà la déglaciation
voilà la variation de température du
dernier siècle voilà la variation de
température vers laquelle on se dirige
avec un scénario
ligne de pente on va dire
voilà on commence à faire des efforts
quand ça commence à aller mal
donc vous voyez à comparer à l'évolution
de la déglaciation s'est
considérablement plus violents et donc
avant de vous détailler très rapidement
quelques conséquences l'une des choses
qui est absolument certaine si on joue
l'expérience des 3 degrés en 2100 c'est
que ça se terminera avec la guerre
partout pas juste la guerre en ukraine
la guerre partout l'état standards du
monde sera un état chaotique violent
absolument pas démocratique où nous
aurons en gros un monde vraiment pas
sympathique moi je vous le souhaite pas
et je me souhaite pas à moi même puisque
j'ai évidemment l'intention de vivre un
siècle et demi
je suis sérieux
ccc on est vraiment en train de parler
pardon de citer les bons auteurs de
guerre et paix enfin je veux dire c'est
de ça dont on parle est évidemment la
préservation de la paix n'est pas
comprise aujourd'hui dans notre système
économique c'est-à-dire que quand on
paye aujourd'hui un objet qui va
conduire à émettre des gaz à effet de
serre le fait que ça va déclencher la
guerre c'est pas inclus dans le prix 1
pour rien
alors dans les conséquences sympathique
une partie croissante je vais aller très
vite je suis désolé une partie
croissante des régions du monde va
devenir inhabitable parce qu il fera
trop souvent dans l'année chaud et
humide
et quand la température extérieure
dépasse 35 degrés dans un air saturé
d'humidité on meurt
donc là c'est le nombre de jours par an
en fonction de l'élévation de
température et de l'horizon où l'état
deviendra inhabitable ça va concerner
quelques millions de personnes quelques
milliards par tant de personnes
les précipitations vont baisser à
certains endroits l'évaporation va
augmenter tout de suite partout bardon
est donc une fraction très importante
des terres émergées vont devenir va
devenir plus sèches
ici vous avez en marron toutes les
régions du monde qui deviennent plus ou
moins plus sèches dans un monde qui se
réchauffe et de 2 degrés voyez tout le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen et
concernés dont la france toute
l'amérique est concerné sauf rares
exceptions toute la chine est concerné
enfin voilà donc quelques milliards de
personnes là aussi et l'essentiel de la
production agricole mondiale qui est
concerné
dans un monde à deux degrés et un tiers
des terres émergées voit sa biodiversité
s'effondrer là vous avez l'évolution de
143 zone d'intérêt pour la biodiversité
des que c'est en pourpre c'est que en
gros vous avez une perte majeure
d'habitat
et ça c'est dans un monde à deux degrés
et l'ensemble de ses zones représentent
à peu près un tiers des terres émergées
donc la biodiversité s'effondrent elles
s'effondrent déjà pour d'autres raisons
mais
à deux degrés l'insécurité alimentaire
augmente partout dans le monde
alors là c'est pas quantifié en termes
de degrés mais les ouragans vont
s'intensifier ça c'est quelque chose qui
est assez facile à comprendre parce que
la température au sol va augmenter mais
la température de la stratosphère va
baisser ce qui veut dire que le la
différence de température entre le sol
et la haute atmosphère augmente et ça ça
intensifie la convection ce qui met en
route les phénomènes extrêmes donc les
ouragans ça c'est dans les modèles et
probablement les tornades et les orages
vont également gagné en intensité
l'océan va monter parce que l'eau chaude
et se dilate par rapport à l'eau froide
et que les glaçons sur terre vont fondre
et à l'horizon de quelques siècles
l'océan pourrait monter de plus de 15
mètres et le déclencheur on est en train
de le gérer en ce moment alors si on
veut pas que tout ce bazar
qu'est ce qu'on fait vous avez ici une
courbe qui vous représente la réponse en
température du système climatique en
fonction de la quantité totale de co2
qu'on met dans l'atmosphère a comme le
co2 à une très longue durée de vie
encore une fois c'est la quantité totale
qui compte
à fin 2020 on avait mis dans
l'atmosphère à peu près de 1300
milliards de tonnes de co2 et en
conséquence de quoi la température est
monté de 1,1 degré en gros
si on veut tenir la corde paris 1,5
degré à ce moment on fait le chemin
inverse et il faut qu'on se limite à
environ
3000 milliards de tonnes au total d'ici
à 2100 dont 2300 déjà été émise donc on
a apprend une budgétaire classique 1
vous avez trois mille euros à dépenser
vous en avez déjà dépensé 2300 bas et
vous aurez 700
voilà c'est exactement pareil on a trois
mille milliards de tonnes à émettre au
total on en a déjà émis 2300 il nous en
reste sept cents
si je rapporte 700 milliards de tonnes
aux 80 ans qui viennent et au fait qu'on
est en moyenne 9 milliards sur terre et
que je compare ça au 2300 qu'on a déjà
émises à une époque on était en moyenne
plutôt 3 milliards
ça revient à dire qu'un enfant qui naît
aujourd'hui
il a en gros le droit d'émettre un
dixième des émissions que ses
grands-parents qui mouraient aujourd'hui
on est miss pendant leur vie c'est à peu
près ça l'ordre de grandeur qu'il faut
avoir en tête
si on veut se limiter à 2 degrés à ce
moment on a droit à 3500 3600 milliards
de tonnes et mon enfant est beaucoup
mieux loti il a droit plutôt au sixième
des émissions de ses grands parents
sachant que les émissions je vais pas
avoir le temps de détailler au go pilote
le niveau de vie ça revient à dire que
l'enfant qui naît aujourd'hui il va
devoir consommer 10 fois moins sa vie
durant que ce que ses grands-parents qui
meurent aujourd'hui ont conservé leur
vie durant
c'est exactement ça que ça veut dire il
faut que son pouvoir d'achat moyen sur
sa vie soit divisée par dix
c'est ça le cahier des charges des deux
d 1,5 degré et par six si on tient les 2
degrés
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en tête alors
vous comprenez maintenant que ça va pas
se faire d'un claquement de doigts et
que ça ne va pas se faire par un miracle
décidée par un gouvernement au sein
d'une population
ou le sujet économique continue à être
la première préoccupation
ça ne se fera pas dans ce contexte là
c'est absolument certain
je vais vous le dire autrement ça veut
dire que les émissions doivent être
divisé par trois au moins d'ici à 2050
et alors pour tous les gens dans cette
salle qui sont familiers des intérêts
composés s'il ya un banquier qui s'est
introduit ici par inadvertance une
division par trois en trente ans ça
revient à ce que on est une baisse de 5%
par an
tous les ans entre maintenant et 2050 or
5% de baisse c'est ce qu'on a eue
l'année du coc vide en 2020 en 2020 les
émissions planétaires ont baissé de 5%
eh bien il faudrait qu'on ait un
qu'ovide supplémentaires tous les ans
pour tenir les deux degrés
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en tête
je vais vous le dire autrement il n'y a
aucune chance qu'on résolve ce problème
je dis bien aucune chance qu'on résolve
ce problème si on se met pas dans
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
économie de guerre aucune
et si on ne résout pas le problème de
nous mêmes ces problèmes qui s'occupera
de nous parce que bien évidemment dans
un monde qui se réchauffe et au surplus
en pénurie de moyens parce qu'à un
moment les combustibles fossiles façon
on en aura de moins en moins qu'on le
veuille ou qu'on le veuille pas parce
qu'ils sont épuisables un monde dans
lequel on n'a plus de maire de man a
géré avec moins de moyens c'est un monde
qui implosent de toute façon
donc faut pas croire qu'on va avoir une
sortie facile de cette affaire il y en
aura pas
et plus on procrastine plus le moment où
la sortie involontaire se fera sera
désagréable
c'est un problème très classique
d'addiction que nous avons tant que ça
passe c'est très sympa mais plus ça
passe quand ans et plus la fin de
l'histoire risque d'être désagréable
alors si on regarde d'où viennent les
émissions je vais terminer par ça voilà
un petit camembert qui vous donne la
répartition aujourd'hui 20% des
émissions planétaires c'est les
centrales électriques à charbon
tougas confondues dont la moitié se
trouve en chine
donc 80% se trouve en asie c'est à dire
de la dont vienne d'où viennent par dont
les semi-conducteurs les dalles d'écrans
les composants de réseaux les ouailles
et autres fournisseurs de machin c'est à
dire tous les gens sans lesquels vous
n'existez pas moi non plus du reste
puisque j'utilise un ordinateur
7 à 8 % des émissions planétaires
viennent des centrales à gaz des
centrales électriques à gaz ce qui veut
dire que la production électrique à base
de combustible fossile qui fait
aujourd'hui à peu près 60% de la
production totale dans le monde et qui a
et qui est celle qui a le plus augmenté
sur les 20 dernières années c'est pas du
tout la production électrique à base de
renouvela pilote plus augmenté sur les
20 dernières années c'est la production
à base de combustible fossile d'un
et bien représentent un gros quart des
émissions planétaires les cimenteries
représentent 4% des émissions je les ai
mises à part parce que la production de
ciment sa aimé à cause de l'utilisation
de l'énergie un four à ciment c'est un
truc qu'on chauffe très fort mais
également à cause du fait que l'on casse
les molécules de carbonate de calcium en
deux dans une cimenterie de calcaire en
deux et ça ça fait du co2 aussi
le reste de procédés industriels c'est
12% et là dedans je parle des émissions
directes je parle pas de l'électricité
qui est consommé là dedans vous avez 4 %
pour les hauts fourneaux également et 4%
pour la chimie de base donc fabriquer
des matériaux de base c'est ça qui est
mais de manière massive au sein de
l'industrie une fois qu'on a fait
l'acier le transformer en portière de
voiture ou en bus long de 12 ça c'est
moins émissifs 5% des émissions
planétaires c'est les chaudières de
bâtiments
de l'ordre de 14 à 15% c'est le moyen de
transport dans lesquels on va trouver 6
% pour les 1,2 million 1,2 c 5 milliards
de voitures que nous avons sur terre
4% pour les camions je connais pas leur
nombre exact 2 % pour la marine
marchande et 2% pour les 20000 avions et
en ce moment tout le monde se félicite
du fait que le trafic aérien reparte à
la hausse et que enfin les français
puissent retourner à miami ce que j'ai
vu dans un reportage télévisé ya pas
longtemps juste après qu'on se demande
si le nouveau gouvernement allait être
sérieuse sur les questions
d'environnement enfin ça n'a jamais la
cohérence et les journalistes à fait
assez souvent de
20% des émissions planétaires viennent
de l'agroalimentaire au plus exactement
de l'agriculture peu de
l'agroalimentaire c'est des émissions
d'origine agricole là dedans vous avez
la méthanisation des bovins vous avez la
méthanisation des rizières vous avez le
protoxyde d'azoté émis par les engrais
après épandage on ne sait pas leur
fabrication c'est l'épandage des engrais
et enfin vous avez la gestion des
déjections animales tout ça ça émet du
ca émettent du méthane et vous avez un
tout petit peu le co2 détracteurs mais
c'est totalement marginal dans cet
ensemble c'est essentiellement des
émissions hors co2 qui compte 10 % c'est
la déforestation je voulais dit tout à
l'heure c'est un processus amont de
l'agriculture sont coupe des surfaces
pour faire des champs ou pour faire des
pâturages ce qui veut dire que la
fonction alimentaire au sens large c'est
un tiers des émissions planétaires et là
je le répète vous avez deux déterminants
la taille de la population humaine plus
on est nombreux plus on mange et la
fraction de viande dans la ration
alimentaire donc si on est contre la
déforestation il faut qu'on s'intéresse
à d'autres trucs qui sont le planning
familial et la viande dans la ration
alimentaire
et enfin 7 % des émissions viennent de
processus divers la gestion des déchets
les fuites de fluides frigorigènes etc
alors là dedans je répète il ya le
numérique dont vous dépendez qui joue un
rôle en 2018 le chiffre project avait
sorti un rapport qui est celui qui
adapte nous a valu le plus grand nombre
de citations médias jusque dans le hindu
times et d'autres journaux étrangers
dans lequel on s'intéressait à
l'empreinte carbone du numérique et à la
manière éventuellement d'essayer de le
modérer alors je vais vous sortir trois
chiffres sur l'empreinte carbone du
numérique le premier 6 4% aujourd'hui
six jeux cij agrège les émissions
annuelles de fabrication des smartphones
des ordinateurs des serveurs des
composants de réseaux et le
fonctionnement du système donc la grève
les deux donc tout ce qui vient du
digital j'obtiens à peu près 4 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
planète c'est à dire l'équivalent de la
flotte mondiale de camions ou deux fois
les émissions de la marine marchande
dont dire que le digital c'est
dématérialisée bas comme aurait dit
zazie pas la chanteuse l'héroïne de
queneau montcuq pas dématérialisée du
tout
la deuxième chose qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est le double de 4 % c'est-à-dire
8% c'est à peu près le rythme de
croissance des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre du digital donc s'il ya un truc
qui n'est pas soutenable dans le monde
sait ça
s'il ya un truc qui n'est pas soutenable
dans le monde ces digital
vous avez ici la décomposition par poste
de la consommation d'énergie du digital
donc vous voyez en gros moitié
fabrication moitié fonctionnement les
serveurs sont très peu présents dans la
fabrication très présent dans le
fonctionnement
par contre les terminaux des
utilisateurs
typiquement l'ordinateur que j'ai là
sont très présents dans la fabrication
très peu dans le fonctionnement ce qui
veut dire que pour les serveurs on a
intérêt à les renouveler aussi souvent
que possible si jamais ça économise un
peu de fonctionnement par contre pour
les terminaux on a intérêt à les
renouveler le moins souvent possible
même si ça consomme un peu moins donc si
vous voulez faire un truc utile dans le
design fait en sorte que les gens aient
pas besoin d'autres gradés leur
smartphone et l'ordinateur en permanence
pour utiliser le dernier grigris à la
mode qui vous fait piché comme pas
possible
un des arrêts si vous voulez être
compatible avec le problème que je viens
d'évoquer fait du low tech
est alors dans le low tech ne fait pas
de vidéo
la vidéo aujourd'hui ses 80 % du trafic
de données sur le réseau mondial
vous avez la décomposition là donc les
vidéos en ligne c'est les services on va
dire donc youtube le porno netflix
les autres vidéos c'est des trucs que
vous envoyez votre soeur à votre frère
votre tante quand le petit dernier a
fait sa première dans ce dont tout le
monde se fout sauf ou de restes voilà
c'est ça les autres ou la vidéo de votre
chien qui a fait pourquoi une mine qui a
renversé sa gamelle en mettant ses pas
de danse voilà donc c'est ça c'est les
autres vidéos donc la vidéo en ligne la
vidéo sur internet c'est 80 % donc fait
des sites sans vidéo
c'est très simple faites des sites qui
nécessite pas de remplacer matériel fait
des sites sans vidéo
dans les deux minutes qui me reste je
reviens à ce gars à ce graphique et ce
graphique
je vous en jeu vous je vous précise une
chose là dessus c'est que à peu près 60%
des émissions donc c'est beaucoup mais
c'est pas tous viennent de l'utilisation
de l'énergie donc le fait qu'on brûle du
pétrole du gaz du charbon
cause des émissions
pourquoi est ce que on s'est mis à
utiliser de l'énergie sur terre alors
c'est assez simple on s'est mis à
utiliser de l'énergie sur terre parce
que c'est achement bon parce que il ya
quelques siècles voilà à quoi
ressemblait le monde dans lequel on
vivait 100% renouvelable je dis bien
100% renouvelable donc incidemment faire
un monde 100 % renouvelable de pose
aucun problème
c'est le monde dans lequel nous avons
vécu nous l'humanité depuis nos origines
jusqu'à il ya deux siècles
donc faire un monde 100 % renouvelable
de pose aucun problème faire un monde
100 % renouvelable en gardant les acquis
de la civilisation industrielle ça
n'arrivera pas donc on peut faire un
monde 100 % renouvelable si on veut il
n'y a pas de problème avec ça ça n'est
absolument pas le monde dans lequel nous
vivons aujourd'hui absolument pas parce
que le monde dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui il a été permis par
l'avènement des combustibles fossiles et
l'avènement des combustibles fossiles ça
nous a permis de faire ça
les combustibles fossiles
c'est la bibine d'iron man iron man est
un personnage dont on sert énormément
dans la bd que j'ai montré tout à
l'heure et qui symbolise en fait le parc
de machines qui aujourd'hui travaillent
pour nous et qui nous rend exactement
les mêmes services qu iron man il a
juste pas la même forme donc nous avons
tous en permanence sur nos épaules un
costume d'iron man ou d'iron man ou
d'ailleurs une personne
qui nous rend exactement les mêmes
services que ceux que tu que que pardon
services que le costume dans la bd de
marvel
c'est à dire que le bras gauche d'iron
man eh bien c'est la pelle hydraulique
ou c'est la presse hydraulique dans
l'industrie le petit doigt gauche et
iron man c'est le train qui transporte
des marchandises ou les passagers l'oeil
d'iron man c'est le satellite ou le
télescope qui voit extrêmement loin et
c'est la bouche iron man c'est un grand
aspirateur donc vous avez aujourd'hui à
notre disposition un parc de machines
qui est d'une puissance absolument
considérable et juste pour vous donner
un exemple une voiture aujourd'hui ces
puissants comme des centaines de paires
de jambes donc si vous aviez besoin
d'esclaves pour avancer à la même
vitesse que votre voiture vous auriez
besoin de 500 domestique payer pour
tirer la voiture évidemment vous auriez
pas les moyens donc absolument personne
dans cette salle ne roulerait en voiture
sans combustibles fossiles
c'est pareil pour l'avion c'est pareil
pour et c est tout ce que vous portez
sur vous tous et c'est tout partout et
fabriqué par des machines en fait si
vous regardez
la puissance des machines installées sur
terre aujourd'hui elles sont permis
grâce à leur nourriture particulière de
multiplier la puissance des bras et des
jambes des hommes par deux sens donc en
fait consommer de l'énergie c'est un
terme impropre vous consommez pas de
l'énergie vous domestique est une
machine consommer de l'énergie ses
domestiques et une machine et le monde
que nous avons créée est un monde de
machines grâce aux combustibles fossiles
et ça fait évidemment des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre donc déterminé par
ça
ici vous avez un petit graphique qui
vous symbolise la façon dont le monde
moderne peut s'écrire on a des
combustibles fossiles qui comme toutes
les ressources naturelles sur terre sont
gratuits alors vous allez me dire avec
l'essence atelier à deux euros le litre
c'est pas gratuit ici c'est gratuit
quand vous payer deux euros le litre
d'essence vous ne payez pas la nature
vous payer d'autres hommes et d'autres
femmes qui ont trouvé l'essence fait
sauf à trouver le pétrole fait sortir le
pétrole des états pétroliers qui
réclament des taxes au passage l'état
français qui réclament des taxes au
passage tout ça c'est que des hommes il
n'y a pas de nature là dedans
l'existence du pétrole sur terre est
aussi gratuite que l'existence du vent
est aussi gratuit ces combustibles
fossiles nous ont permis grâce à leur
combustion d'alimenter des machines qui
ont transformé tout le reste de nice qui
tombait dessus de ce qui nous tombait
sous la main pardon et qui est gratuit
aussi ça fait les 100 millions d'objets
qui sont présents maintenant sur les
sites de commerce en ligne que vous
désignez peut-être et c'est l'abondance
de ces machines qui travaillent pour
nous a permis de diviser par deux à
trois le temps travaillé des hommes en
l'espace d'un siècle et nous avons
affecté ce temps libre à prendre notre
retraite à faire des études longues à
partir en vacances à être en week-end et
à travailler 35 heures par semaine
tout ça c'est des machines donc les
retraites c'est les machines donc
rallonger l'âge de la retraite qu'on le
veuille ou qu'on le veuille pas c'est ce
qui va nous arriver dans un monde plus
avant il n'y avait pas de retraite il ya
un siècle et demi ça n'existait pas le
monde n'était pas assez productif c'est
à dire pas assez doté en machine pour
que les machines produisent à la fois
pour les gens dits travaillant et
légendes il ne travaille en parle
ça n'existait pas il n'y avait pas
d'études longues il ya un siècle et demi
parce qu'elle ait pas de machine il n'y
avait pas de tourisme lointain il n'y
avait pas d'économie mondialisée il n'y
avait pas d'économie de service parce
qu'elle ait pas de machine
donc tout ce que nous avons fait autour
de nous c'est les machines et
aujourd'hui tous les postes du
gouvernement pour parler de cette
accroche dans l'actualité récente
dépendent des machines ya pas que le
poste de l'aide du ministre la
transition énergétique donc madame
bornes et monsieur macron dirige un
monde de machines c'est ça qu'on dirige
vraiment est dans un monde dans lequel
il y aura moins de machines parce que
c'est ça la sobriété énergétique c'est
impactera tous y compris les retraites
l'aménagement du territoire et la
réforme de la fonction publique tout ça
dépend de l'abondance énergétique
voilà et l'abondance énergétique donc il
ya deux sujets qui sont susceptibles de
la limite et 1 dont je vous ai un peu
parlé le réchauffement climatique dont
je vous ai pas parlé du tout qui est la
limite à l'amont mais la limite à la
main elle a déjà commencé à s'exercer
donc là je rentrerai pas dans les
détails le chi project a sorti plusieurs
rapports sur la question l'un des
rapports dit pour vous le dire en 15
secondes que selon toute vraisemblance
les 16 premiers producteurs mondiaux de
pétrole or au brésil et canada on n'a
pas regardé ses dollars mais ça change
pas grand chose devraient voir leur
production globale diviser par deux
d'ici à 2050 et donc la quantité de
pétrole dont on disposera en europe qui
importent l'union européenne apporte 95%
du pétrole qu'elle consomme devra être
divisée par n'importe quoi entre deux
ils disent qu'on le veuille ou qu'on le
veuille pas
donc la sobriété carbonique de toute
façon on va avoir et encore une fois on
l'aura soit de manière gérer je pense
que c'est préférable soit de manière
subi auquel cas la décrue se fera par
marche d'escalier dont le co vider la
guerre en ukraine sont des exemples
parmi d'autres
et j'ai terminé
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pas si ça marche ça marche et
est ce qu'on a envie de poser des
questions maintenant pas je sais pas
si sûrement il ya deux micros qui se
promène dans la salle n'hésitez pas à
lever les mains et en vous prêtera là on
vous donnera la parole
ado oui c'est bon
bah merci beaucoup c'est
vraiment beaucoup apprécié votre
conférence
alors déjà andy pas
désarmé design voilà je préférais le
dire
quoi concrètement donc j'ai retenu qu'on
doit pas faire de vidéos dans nos sites
on doit quasiment effectivement rien
consommer du tout est-ce que tant dans
les initiatives que vous avez pu creuser
je tire dans le monde du numérique vous
avez des exemples de de gens qui font
mieux que les autres vont dans le
numérique
quand ce soit sur la consommation
d'énergie ou sur le type de de produits
numériques en particulier pas prendre
pas vraiment et pas même le chi project
puisque nous venons mais de la vidéo en
ligne
aujourd'hui on est
tous les tous les secteurs qui
découvrent l'ampleur du problème passe
tous par les phases par lesquelles nous
passons nous mêmes quand on découvre un
truc qui nous déplaît vous savez il ya
au début le déni ensuite la colère le
deuil de j'ai pas quoi bon bref le
numérique se baladent globalement
aujourd'hui entre le déni et la colère
la découverte du problème et récents
alors déjà il ya eu cet abus de langage
qui a consisté à parler moi je suis si
fernand vieux pour avoir vécu ça de la
dématérialisation quand on a cessé
d'utiliser des factures papier alors
qu'en fait on a matérialisé le système
encore plus qu'avant le système papier
était globalement moins matériel que le
système à base de la carotte métaux
différents dans cet ordinateur donc
beaucoup plus matérielles
et les gens du secteur ont été tellement
convaincu pendant tellement longtemps
que il amenait une forme de reste le
monde virtuel c'est pareil c'est un abus
total de langage il ya rien de virtuel
dans un ordinateur
la réalité c'est une autre forme de
réalité mais c'est pas du tout virtuel
donc il ya eu il ya eu une espèce de
d'autosuggestion
généralisée qui s'est emparée du secteur
avec d'autres termes comme par exemple
smart quand c'était numérique c'était
smart évidemment si vous êtes smart vous
pouvez pas faire du mal à la planète
parce que si vous faites du mal à la
planète vous êtes plutôt dub donc
et on n'est pas passés de la smart teck
add-on tech d'accord donc là le dans le
monde du numérique s'il ya eu
globalement une espèce de
d'autosuggestion ou d'auto intoxication
jeu pas comment il faut le dire sur le
fait que tout ce qui était fait aller
globalement dans le bon sens alors une
fois que le numérique ces enduits
digital s'est rendu compte que c'était
pas aussi simple que ça on a vu arriver
par exemple à partir après la
publication du rapport du chiffre
project tout un tir de barrage de gens
qui disent en oui mais le numérique
permettre dé carbonée reste alors y
avait un truc qui a été sponsorisée par
orange je veux dire du mal d'orange dès
que ce soit un client de carbone 4 qui a
sorti une publication avec une méthode
ni fait ni à faire en expliquant que les
émissions du numérique permettait
d'économiser dix fois les émissions du
numérique en dehors du secteur alors je
vais vous donner une règle de trois les
émissions du numérique c'est 4 % des
émissions mondiales si on économise 10
fois en dehors du secteur c'est à dire
40 % des émissions mondiales
si les émissions mondiales avaient dû
baisser de 40% je pense qu'on s'en
serait rendu compte
donc bien évidemment ce calcul ne repose
sur rien complètement démentie par les
faits de façon absolument évidente je
vois pas en quoi le porno cd carbone
l'économie
un peu de mal à comprendre un
petit shoot c'est à mon avis un
les gens dansent à calmer les ardeurs
sont quand même pas très fréquent donc
non d'une manière générale on voit on
voit bien que il ya 80% du vide et flic
c'est pareil je vois pas en quoi ça des
carbones l'économie de regarder netflix
donc là là l'irruption du digital en
fait aujourd'hui prend à rebours prend à
revers une bonne partie des gens qui
était considéré de façon très positive
jusqu'à maintenant
danger dans le discours et dans le et
cetera donc on est encore dans la phase
du déni du déni et de la colère envie de
dire des gens qui essayent de faire des
choses qui soient vraiment d'autre et de
jeu extrêmement
smart pour le coup décarbonée il y en a
pas beaucoup
on t'en reste de l'économie il y en a
pas tellement non plus
c'est souvent des petites entreprises
dire que les grandes entreprises après
il ya un problème plus général les
grandes entreprises elles sont
prisonnières de la rente dans le monde
tel qu'il existe
donc penser que les grandes entreprises
vont faire la révolution chez elle à
quelques exceptions près ça sera pas le
cas c'est impossible
oui bonjour j'ai une petite question
je trouve toujours c'est un petit peu
angoissant même beaucoup et en sortant
de cette pièce qu'est ce que vous auriez
aimé que l'on fasse que l'on change dans
nos vies
passer du temps à regarder ce que
signifie le problème la raison pour
laquelle on a je le redis j'ai signé
cette tribune pour 20 heures de
formation pour les ministres donc là
vous avez eu quelques parcs quelque
chose qui ressemble à une demi heure de
formation en une demi heure de formation
vous réorienter pas une vie pour
réorienter une vie il faut 20 heures et
quand j 20 heures il faut plutôt au sens
et senteurs de formation ça veut dire
passer du temps jamais on a réussi à
résoudre un problème important sans y
passer du temps si vous avez ce que je
ne vous souhaite pas un problème majeur
avec un de vos enfants vous n'allez pas
résoudre le problème sans y passer du
temps donc là on a un problème majeur
avec la direction comprend
collectivement on ne s'en sortira jamais
sans y passer du temps donc la première
marche de l'escalier c'est d'y passer du
temps
après il n'y a pas de solution qui soit
presse bouton pour tout le monde partout
tout le temps il ya des partages
d'expériences qui sont utiles si vous
écoutez quelqu'un qui est dans le btp ou
la chimie vous expliquer comment il a
abordé le problème mais il ya des choses
dont vous allez éventuellement pouvoir
vous inspirer parce que ça relève de la
nature humaine ça relève du partage
d'expériences et des trucs qui vous
serviront strictement à rien comment
est-ce que je petit mise le débit de
telles substances et telles températures
dentelle tuyaux vous pas beaucoup vous
aider voilà donc qui
il passait du temps
il n'y a pas tellement d'autres réponses
à faire
vraiment c'est ça la première marche
et dans un premier temps pardon pour la
répétition du bronze c'est pas sympa
c'est pas sympa parce que la première
fois que le médecin vous annonce que
vous allez mourir peut-être passer du
temps pour comprendre de quoi exactement
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
exactement vous n'êtes pas trop envie
mais c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
bonjour merci beaucoup pour la
présentation il y avait une question qui
est un peu dans la dans le même la même
veine que la question précédente c'est
finalement de votre expérience dans les
interventions dans la sphère politique
ce que j'ai l'impression que le problème
est politique
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à ce niveau
là effectivement je pense qu'on peut
tous prendre du temps essayé de se
documenter et ses terrains mais mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait au niveau politique
finalement lorsqu'on fait au niveau
politique ça dépend beaucoup du système
dans lequel on est si vous êtes en chine
ce qui est important c'est de parler
directement aux dirigeants parce que les
dirigeants sont dans une position dans
laquelle il ya une partie des choses qui
peuvent imposer à la population
si vous êtes en france qui est pour le
moment une démocratie vous êtes dans un
cahier des charges totalement différent
puisque la démocratie est
malheureusement ou heureusement une
espèce de démagogie organisé donc en
démocratie le problème se termine avec
les élus il commence pas avec les élus
ce qui veut dire qu'en démocratie faut
parler aux électeurs ce qui est beaucoup
plus long mais c'est comme ça
le monde politique je fréquente
maintenant depuis vingt ans
j'ai fini par comprendre que je suis un
peu lent à la comprenette qu'en fait ça
sert pas à grand chose de lui parler
tant que vous n'avez pas avec vous une
partie de la population qui va dans le
sens de ce que vous venez défendre
aller parler à un élu en lui disant on a
un problème et j'ai un plan à vous
proposer qui répond au problème ça ne
sert strictement à rien tant que vous
n'avez pas une troisième carte dans
votre jeu qui est une capacité de
nuisance si le plan n'est pas mise en
oeuvre c'est à dire en fait
l'assentiment d'une partie de la
population pour vouloir le mettre en
oeuvre
c'est la raison pour laquelle le chip
project en fait depuis son origine 2010
n'a jamais cherché à s'adresser
directement aux élus sauf exception un
peu aux élus locaux parce que nos
différents
et il s'est toujours a toujours cherché
à s'adresser aux à la société civile en
direct
notamment ovidio économique au milieu
académique et à la haute fonction
publique c'est ça les cibles qui nous
intéresse le monde politique ne nous
intéresse quand ce qui sera entraînée
par les milieux que je viens d'évoquer
mais allait s'adresser directement aux
groupes politiques ça sert à rien ça
sert à faire de la com mais voilà sinon
ça sert pas à grand chose tant qu'on n'a
pas je le redis l'assentiment de la de
la société civile
bonjour et merci c'est toujours aussi
oppressant de faire ces constats mais je
vous remercie quand même
dernièrement j'ai entendu l'appel ait
déserté des étudiants de agroparistech
j'imagine que vous l'avez entendu
c'était assez ans pire en fait et pour
quelqu'un comme moi qui viens du design
mais qui s'intéresse de plus en plus la
permaculture les modes de vie entre
guillemets alternatif et qui se pose
sérieusement la question la légitimité
dans ce domaine ici
je crois que j'espère encore peut-être
de changer les choses de l'intérieur
tout en me demandant si c'est pas plus
intéressant de tout quitter et d'aller
effectivement faire de la permaculture à
detroit ou autre à detroit pourquoi
détroit parce que c'est un des endroits
où il ya le plus de permaculture
actuellement justement parce que j'avais
l'impression de revenir en france en
avion dans l'entente ou pas c'est un peu
seul problème c'est justement ouais si
vous allez à detroit il faut il fermer
pays sinon c'est exactement et plus
revenir
une alternative mais bon aujourd'hui on
en est plus est justement d
des consensus alors quelques j'ai
évidemment vu cette vidéo d'un groupe
paritaire faire des étudiants d'accord
paristech il ya à la fois dans cette
vidéo de lembras des choses auxquelles
j'adhère et des choses auxquelles
j'adhère -
ce qui a alors pour commencer par la
partie sur laquelle j'adhère moins quand
on est jeune puisque je suis passé par
là aussi je vois directement passé de
bba vieux con un étudiant un peu naïf
oui c'est un truc les enfants du mal à
comprendre
on est toujours un peu naïf et donc on a
une vision du monde qui est toujours un
peu simpliste donc voilà on n'a pas
encore assez d'expérience pour
comprendre comment les choses s'articule
donc il ya une partie naïve danse est un
peu yaka ça suffit etc mais c'est pas
très grave le message essentiel est
ailleurs le message essentiel c'est ce
qu'on va faire de nos propres vies n'est
pas complètement neutre dans l'évolution
du système et donc on a le choix et en
particulier moi la question qui me
paraît intéressante à développer à
partir de leurs interventions c'est si
on a envie d'agir est ce qu'il faut être
dedans ou dehors alors là j'ai un une
réponse très claire quand on est jeune
faut d'abord penser qu'on va changer les
choses dans une entreprise dans une
grande entreprise
en rentrant quand on est jeune
malheureusement ça n'existe pas
vous arrivez à changer les choses dans
une entreprise paradoxalement quand vous
comprenez bien comment elle fonctionne
et donc vous avez de l'expérience par
ailleurs que vous avez une légitimité la
légitimité dans une entreprise
s'acquiert par des responsabilités
opérationnelles moins fonctionnel dont
faut être patron d'une bévue d'une zone
d'un produit j'sais pas quoi
d'une faute d'une ligne de fabrication
sauf que une fois que vous avez fait ça
en fait vous avez contribué à entretenir
le problème et cette manière de faire
vous êtes devenue familière c'est
compliqué de faire la révolution
derrière donc être
il ya deux bon moment pour agir c'est le
moment où vous êtes jeunes parce que
vous avez envie de faire des choses mais
à ce moment dans l'entreprise c'est
compliqué donc c'est mieux d'agir depuis
l'extérieur et un deuxième moment c'est
au moment où vous commencez à des clés
parce que là vous êtes finalement vous
avez tout compris
et si éventuellement ce que vous avez
compris vous convient pas vous pouvez
milité pour que les choses se passent
autrement sans trop de conflits
d'intérêts puisque vous êtes sortant du
système donc le mode alliance c'est
entre les jeunes et les vieux à
l'extérieur ça j'ai envie de dire
la deuxième chose intéressante c'est de
rentrer directement dans une entité qui
est aligné avec le sujet
donc effectivement faire ou la
permaculture ou entrer dans une
exploitation agricole qui fait les
choses qui paraissent qui paraissent
intelligente ou lier à l'hfr jeu
pourquoi un atelier de réparation de
vélos rentrer dans une boîte et même
dans le secteur qui est le vôtre c'est
évident que ça renvoie la question qui a
été posée tout à l'heure il ya
probablement moi je les connais pas mais
il ya probablement des entités mais qui
sont souvent des petites entités encore
une fois un l'innovation via des viandes
et challenger des petites entités qui
vont essayer de faire des trucs bien
une autre voie possible est de rentrer
et danser dans ces entités là qui font
un peu plus partie du système que si
vous devenez peintres dans la montagne
mais qui ont quand même une possibilité
de faire changer le système pas ce que
c'est les challengers et donc c'est des
gens qui proposent quelque chose de
différent et qui est en général aligné
d'entrée de jeu ou mieux aligné d'entrée
de jeu avec le cahier des charges je
pensais plus à élever des chèvres ça ira
si vous prenez pas l'avion tous les
quatre matins pour rentrer en france oui
merci
bonjour nous avoir grand fan donc ravi
de vous voir en vrai j'ai une question
vous parlez de du problème là on a vu
une belle exposition et poser le
problème c'est commencer à le résoudre
j'aurais savoir au niveau des solutions
est-ce que de commencer à se former sur
du lot tech d'avoir l'approchent
solutions techniques même la plus de
plus bas niveau ou le travail
d'évangélisation puisqu'on travaille
aussi dans ce domaine là de faire
comprendre notre démarche et deux
finales faire belle tournée la bonne
parole
qu'est ce qui selon vous a le plus
d'impact et ce sur quoi on doit
travailler au final pour faire rentrer
ça dans les consciences de tous c'est
vrai que j'ai déjà autour de moi qu'ils
commencent à se poser des questions et
d'autres qui sont pas du tout convaincu
même avec une exposition a quelques
arguments du coup qu'est ce qui est pour
vous le plus pertinent est ce que c'est
montrer l'exemple ou
être plus théorique la pratique la
théorie qui convient le mieux avec 20
ans du coup de recul les les deux sont
difficilement séparables
vous avez il ya quelques mois un film
que l'on voudrait être entendu parler
que ça fait donc tout cup qui est passé
sur netflix à la suite de quoi dicaprio
qui a l'un des rôles principaux
a été à la fois encensée pour avoir joué
dans ce fil est dénigré parce qu'il a un
mode de vie à titre personnel qui est
très exactement aux antipodes de ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour avancer sur le
sur le sujet donc c'est compliqué
d'expliquer à quelqu'un qui doit pas
fumer quand vous même vous fumez 20
cigarettes par jour de marché assez mal
en général ça s'appelle la mise en
cohérence c'est un des sujets qui
concernent tous les gens qui sont actifs
dans le domaine c'est d'essayer de se
mettre en cohérence m ce qui est plus ou
moins facile on le fait à plus ou moins
grande vitesse de façon plus ou moins
homogènes moi par exemple et des
domaines dans lesquels c'est très facile
pour moi de me mettre en cohérence et
des domaines dans lesquels c'est plus
long voilà mais c'est compliqué de ne
pas associer les deux d'une façon d'une
façon générale les gens qui sont
réticents à changer vous allez vous
rendre compte qu'en fait ils raisonnent
à l'envers par rapport à ce que vous
croyez être leur raisonnement vous
pensez qu'ils sont pas convaincus par
les arguments et c'est pour ça qu'ils
changent pas en fait c'est pas ça ils
n'ont pas envie de changer pour d'autres
raisons et du coup ils vous expliquent
que vos arguments sont pas bons c'est
dans ce sens ça que ça marche les
climatosceptiques historiquement ont
toujours été des gens
qui sont en fait prisonnier d'une rente
quelles qu'elles soient et ils n'ont pas
envie de s'en défaire alors ça peut être
une rampe de réputation ça peut être une
rente économique ça peut être une grande
sociale c'est-à-dire qu'ils occupent un
statut ils ont un cercle d'amis etc des
relations familiales et si ils changent
de valeur il change de point de vue sur
le problème que je viens d'évoquer ils
se coupent de tous ces gens là et c'est
quelque chose qui ne veulent pas
donc les gens qui veulent pas changer en
général c'est pas pour des raisons d'
argumentation rationnelle et donc ça
sert à rien d'essayer de les cons les
convaincre avec une contre argumentation
rationnelle ces gens là il faut beaucoup
plus les convaincre avec en essayant
d'autres méthodes et une des choses qui
est importante pour le passage à
l'action c'est justement le fait que ça
se fasse dans un cadre collectif parce
que si ça se fait dans un cadre
collectif vous barrier le changement
dans les pratiques avec la conservation
du lien social
les gens n'acceptent pas moi le premier
vous le premier de se couper de tout
lien social parce qu'ils ont changé
quelque chose dans leur mode de vie
c'est pas souvent c'est pas suffisamment
pris en compte souvent dans les
préconisations pour passer pour passer à
l'action
oui voici
je suis comme tout le monde ici en train
d'écouter des choses que parfois on
connaît parfois on écoute de nouvelles
et moi j'ai un constant une question
dont constat d'abord c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je vois que les jeunes
ils sont plus sensibles sont plus
courageux ils ont de très bonnes idées
et que la manière dont vous le dites
leur dit que il faut pas qu'il travaille
avec des entreprises qui font des
innovations qui font d'autres choses je
me pose la question si le futur la
france n'est pas pas en péril aussi
parce que d'un côté on dit il faut pas
prendre l'avion d'un autre côté il il
faut le faire pour l'économie on vend
des avions on voit très bien que c'est
une grand succès de l'ue pouvoir le
faire
le les uns circulaire c'est vrai qu'il
est arrivé un peu tard dans nos
consciences et dans nos méthodes et je
suis ravi que ça se pousser que tout le
monde essaie de le faire c'est compliqué
une fois qu'on a sorti quelque chose
déjà dans le marché c'est très difficile
de corriger mais n'empêche que on peut
avec de nouvelles idées
d'entreprises importantes pour pas les
fermer ou pour parler au nom à ce qui
existe en on peut vraiment essayé de
changer les choses à l'intérieur c'est
plus difficile mais à en collectivité
quand on dit en communauté en
les innovations locales on peut faire
des pépites qui peuvent facilement être
ré copier ou copier d'autres pépites à
l'intérieur d'autres pays que l'on
puisse avancer mais moi je trouve que
envoyé un message si difficile aux gens
ça va pas être facile et le contrat je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire soit par des combos litres par
externe créer des entreprises des start
up mais c'est pas donné à tous les
jeunes c'est pas facile et donc il faut
pas alors envoyé des trois absolument
parce qu'on voit bien que les jeunes qui
ont des bonnes idées il reste en france
en tout cas la question est ce que vous
en pensez s'il n'est pas jusqu'au bout
de la réflexion s'il faut que la france
à est de construire les avions
ça n'est qu'une question de temps
ça n'est qu'une question de temps parce
que le pétrole est épuisable et que sans
pétrole on fera pas d'alliés l'avion à
hydrogène ça existe déjà s'appelle la
fusée ariane donc on n'en fera pas
énormément
il ya donc ça n'est qu'une question de
temps l'aviation est né avec le pétrole
en 1945 mon père moi je suis très vieux
mon père n'était donc encore plus vieux
est allaité chercheurs est allé faire un
post doctorat aux états unis dans les
années qu à 50 italie en bateau et
pourtant à l'époque
chercheurs sets ça faisait déjà partie
des profs un
post-doc à l'université c'est ça fait
partie de ce qu'on appelle classiquement
aujourd'hui les catégories
socioprofessionnelles supérieures
donc des gens comme ça n'avait pas accès
à l'avion dans les années 50 donc
l'avion pour tous c'est quelque chose de
très récents c'est dû au pétrole et
quand tu y aura plus de pétrole y aura
plus d'avions pour tous donc on arrêtera
de fabriquer des avions alors est-ce que
ça ça va arriver dans cinq ans dans dix
ans dans cinq ans tendance en temps j'en
sais rien mais ça va arriver un jour
c'est absolument certain on a sorti au
shit project un rapport qui s'appelle
voler en 2050 dans lequel on explique
qu'en fait on ne réussira pas à aligner
l'aviation avec un objectif 2 degrés
sans une baisse organisé du trafic c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
on propose en france d'organiser cette
baisse du trafic en diminuant
progressivement les créneaux de
décollage et d'atterrissage des
aéroports alors en fait comme le dit mes
acolytes sur tous les créneaux de
décollage des créneaux d'atterrissage on
en laisse autant qu'on veut
il ya
donc oui on va faire moins d'avions un
jour c'est absolument évident la seule
question c'est comment est ce que tout
ça va s'organiser et géant revient j'en
reviens à ma conclusion tout à l'heure
c'est est-ce que ça se fera au travers
de crise ou est-ce que ça va se faire de
manière gérer mais il y aura pas de
troisième voie n'y aura pas de troisième
voie donc il peut y avoir des rémissions
transitoire pas le problème par ailleurs
tout le carburant pris par les avions
c'est à dire par des riches parce qu'il
ya des riches qui prennent l'avion en
première approximation sur terre il
l'est au détriment des produits
pétroliers qui reste pour les pauvres
là il ya des arbitrages qui sont des
arbitrages de type équité il faut savoir
qu'un avion c'est une baignoire de
kérosène volant volante pardon
quand vous faites un aller retour
transatlantique vous consommez quelques
centaines de litres de carburant juste
pendant le vol aller retour c'est à dire
la même chose en gros que la
consommation annuelle de carburant d'une
petite voiture
donc là le l'aviation dans le monde ces
huit pour cent du pétrole consommé c'est
un petit 10 % 1 c on parle pas d'eux on
parle pas de rien et c'est à 75% pour se
changer les idées c'est tourisme famille
amis voilà c'est essentiellement ça
passe pas si on met ça dans les besoins
existentiels donc là la question après
la question vous allez poser c'est est
ce qu'on doit faire peur aux jeunes avec
un problème bah oui et non enfin on doit
si on leur cache la vérité la
probabilité qu'on agisse dans la bonne
direction et que cette génération
agissent dans la bonne direction me
paraît pas plus élevé que si on leur
raconte la vérité
l'intérêt de la jeunesse quand même une
très belle définition la jeunesse que
j'aime bien moi c'est ont déjà de temps
qu'on se croit eternal est invincible
donc s'il ya un âge auquel on est
capable de se confronter à des défis
c'est quand même bien celui-là donc je
pense qu' il vaut mieux toutes choses
égales par ailleurs leur parler du
problème que de ne pas leur en parler
juste un petit point de détail sur les
jeunes sont plus motivés oui et non il
ya une étude qui est sorti il ya pas
longtemps jusqu'au cercueil c'est déjà
une version précédente qui regardent la
consommation de trafic aérien par
tranche d'âge
la première consommatrice de trafic
aérien enfin la première tranche d'âge
consommatrice de trafic aérien c'est les
25 34 ans est juste derrière ces des 15
24 ans
donc le fait que les jeunes soient plus
sensibilisés et donc plus acteur
peut-être peut-être pas peut-être sur
certains sujets pas sur d'autres et en
ce qui concerne la consommation
numérique c'est pareil les jeunes sur
des gros consommateurs de numérique donc
le fait que parce que les jeunes sont
plus sensibilisés ils ont globalement un
comportement plus vertueux sur certaines
tendances oui sur d'autres noms en tirer
un constat global c'est difficile
bonjour merci pour la présentation votre
référence ironman en fait m'a inspiré un
peu de questions j'ai un petit soucis en
fait de rapporter toutes les machines
aujourd'hui iron man dans le sens où il
fonctionne avec un réacteur à fusion
qu'ils en soient normalement et
écologique et consomme pas en soi de
d'énergie fossile donc je voulais avoir
votre avis sur la question et pour
rester dans l'univers marvel dans les
derniers avengers il ya tanoh ce qui est
considéré comme le méchant du film qui
supprime 50 % de la population de
l'univers est ce qu en soit c'est pas un
des plus beaux acte écologique qu'on a
vu au cinéma
si tous les gens sauf moi dans la salle
sont d'accord pour faire partie des 50%
ça ne pose pas de problème
est-ce que la fusion va changer quelque
chose à l'avenir réponse non enfin où ça
va arriver tellement tard si ça arrive
un jour qu'on sera hors délai
la fusion aujourd'hui elle est très
propre et très merveilleuse parce
qu'elle n'existe pas en général une fois
que les trucs existent ils sont moins
propre et moins merveilleux mais surtout
on ça arrivera beaucoup trop tard pour
que l'on puisse en faire quoi que ce
soit iter n'est pas un réacteur
électrogène c'est juste un réacteur qui
doit démontrer qu'on est capable de
maintenir une réaction de fusion
quelques minutes le temps de récupérer
plus d'énergie que celle qu'on a
utilisée pour chauffer le plasma
quelques millions de degrés et faire un
réacteur électrogène à fusion si on
arrive à faire un prototype pour dans
quelques décennies ça sera le bout du
monde or il sauf que dans quelques
décennies on doit avoir réglé le
problème que ces voix là ça arrivera
trop tard pour ce qu'on doit faire dans
les quelques décennies qui viennent
l'autre sujet sur la population oui bien
sûr que c'est un sujet la population je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure la question
démographique est un sujet en or c'est
marrant parce qu'aujourd'hui on en parle
peu alors qu'il ya quelques dizaines
d'années quand la préoccupation
environnementale a commencé à augmenter
de manière très forte la préoccupation
environnementale elle a connu un très
très très grande accélère accélération à
la fin des années 60 et au début des
années 70
difficile de savoir exactement pourquoi
à ce moment là il ya plusieurs
événements qui peuvent y avoir concouru
l'une d'entre elles c'est la conquête
spatiale le fait qu'on ait vu la terre
depuis l'espace et donc à ce moment nos
sens nous disent tiens c'est fini pas
très gros bull ça a pu être le premier
choc pétrolier qui a été un gros coup de
semonce sur la disponibilité de
l'énergie et des ressources je sais pas
quoi et danser c'est de ces années là
que date la formation des grands
mouvements environnementaux
greenpeace le bbfc la fin des années 60
aux années 60 greenpeace 70 ses amis de
la terre 70 enfin début des années 70 le
club de rome début des années 70 donc
les travaux de meadows sur la croissance
fin des années 60 donc c'est vraiment
une époque qui a été foisonnante sur ce
sur ce sujet là et à ce moment là
également a été écrit un bouquin alors
exactement qui s'appelait la bombe p et
qui disait la planète va être
surpeuplées et alors aujourd'hui alors
qu'elle l'est objectivement c'est à dire
qu'en gros on est en train d'exploser
les unes derrière les autres toutes les
limites planétaires et le premier
déterminant de ça c'est la démographie
c'est un c'est un sujet de débat qui
n'existe plus tellement ce qui est un
peu ce qui m'étonne un peu alors une
fois qu'on a dit que c'était un sujet
cela étant ce n'est pas un sujet facile
à traiter c'est pas un sujet facile à
traiter parce que la question des
enfants c'est quand même un truc qui est
extrêmement affectif tripale sa touche
nos instincts celui de la reproduction
ça touche à des convictions morales
religieuses etc donc c'est des débats
qui sont des débats mr2 par excellence
mais c'est un sujet c'est un sujet et
donc il ya de mon point de vue c'est pas
illogique c'est pas impertinence et même
très pertinent de commencer à essayer
d'aborder ce genre de sujet de la façon
la plus douce possible
et il ya pour conclure ce point là un
homme qui a été chef économiste de l'afd
pendant quelques années qui par ailleurs
est un prêtre jésuite javel gaël giraud
et problème en quelques personnes dans
la salle qu'ils connaissent un peu c'est
un économiste également
qui avait dit dans une déclaration
publique que si on était sérieux sur
l'aide au développement dans ce pays au
lieu d'aider les pays à faire des ponts
et des routes ont les adrets à faire
trois choses qui sont des facteurs
limitant volontairement de la
démographie qui sont
la maîtrise de leur destin par les
femmes ce que en anglais on appelle en
powermat dans lequel il ya évidemment
l'accès à l'éducation
parce que les femmes éduquées et
maîtresses de leur destin font moins
d'enfants que les autres voilà c'est un
constat la deuxième c'est évidemment
l'accès aux musées aux modes de
contraception
et la troisième c'est l'accès à des
régimes de solidarité nationale quand
vous avez des régimes de retraite ou des
trucs jean sécu eh bien on est moins
tenté de faire beaucoup d'enfants pour
compter sur eux quand on est malade ou
vieux
donc ça c'est des modes d'action qu'on
peut considérer comme étant des modes
qui sont pas sanguinaire et violent sûr
c'est un peu moins violent que ce qui se
passe dans avengers le risque évidemment
à ne pas faire ce genre de choses c'est
que la régulation s'opère par des
méthodes beaucoup plus violente ti
pandémie guerres famines dans la guerre
même la guerre ça diminue pas vite la
population à ces pandémies et famine qui
vont vite guerre facilite les deux
premiers mais c'était visa c'est évident
que si le monde est hors d'équilibré
avec 8 milliards d'habitants sur terre
on ne restera pas indéfiniment à 8
milliards d'habitants sur terre et donc
la bonne question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
va se prendre sur la figure qui régulera
les 8 milliards je laisse à la question
donc le pendant de on ne s'occupe pas de
la question démographique c'est comme
pour changement climatique ou l'énergie
c'est le problème s'occupera de lui tout
seul à nos dépens très vraisemblablement
merci beaucoup merci à toutes et tous
pour vos questions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
m
c'est
là